[Music]
okay do I need to knock you two down a
size oh that's adorable not helping
Naomi so big take out cats all the time
thousands of years old and you still
behave like
children so tiny and so angry you run
back away from Death the death P well
you're lucky you're not lunch Hey
where's Tom where'd he go
rabbit I hear running into the alley and
the kid totally ghosted us yeah he's
gone come on we can't lose
him excuse me watch out coming through
make way for the first jpress who says
it can't
fly
look who finally decided to show up
clear the path
goat let's go you know the drill zodiac
protect the guardian
attack
he kick kick and kick t
attack horse round him
up
something's
here who whoa whoa whoa earthquake nope
put on your shoes
Tom how did you do
that
wa come on oh yeah I'll cover the front
you get the back no this is powerful
foro you and Tom need to go what no get
him to safety he needs you who
Tom Tom look at me I promise I'll
explain everything but right now you
have to go with who I'm not leaving
you blue go no
no
whoa Mrs
Lee
Lou we can make this easy you know what
I want old woman then come and get Get
It Go bring me the
Phoenix your opposable thumbs up for the
Simian sorceress herself monkey the lean
mean shrinky
machine she puts the pork in chop and
the belly in one Pig the ham slam
bringing the heat she's the maniac of
fireo give it up for to
handle that's not bad actually don't
encourage this you said it chees heard
it the
adorable rabbit cute attack she's
flexible she's Fang and you definitely
don't want to find her in your sleeping
bag
snake you can't just put him up like
that whoa dude there's a
[Music]
system who are you how long will the
protective charms down like for 5
minutes okay do I know you man no but I
know you oh wa e you sniffing me yeah
and you reak kid no I don't where's your
grandmother Mrs Lee are you okay okay
keep your shoes on that's not rude at
all there he goes you have track and mud
and all that stuff
okay melee it's so good to see you no
pinching necessary all right we spoke
about this Tom this is who my old
friend and now introducing our starting
lineup what are we a basketball team let
rra to his thing presenting the amazing
the
astonishing zodiac
Warriors first up here's your Wake Up
Call from Mr early bird
himself
booster better of
scary
[Music]
it's too
much Tom Focus I can't I'm losing it
just breathe find something to hold on
to something to Anchor yourself it's
okay you're okay try to hit me what for
real unless you don't think you're up
for
it oh it's on for
face you have to do better than that you
think yuar is just going to stand there
and wait for
you umy does this uh shrinking spell
have an expiration date
holy STP fried rice I feel so
weird we may have a problem hurry Dragon
oh wait wait wait hold
on you okay yeah great okay I'll be
right back
get
[Music]
underwear Tom are you okay do I know you
man no but I been watching over you your
whole life who are
[Music]
you wao I know it's cool your
grandmother was a guardian sworn to
protect
Humanity now the duty of protecting it
is yours very funny right it's time to
start your training oh it's
on who okay hold on no no no no
[Music]
no wait how did you know I was going to
survive I didn't is that a
dragon show off it will be my honor to
to guide you wait we're getting dim some
not everything is what it seems
[Music]
kid
zodiac sworn to protect the guardian
who's the featherweight hi I'm Tom
lactose intolerant and guardian of a
Steph Curry rookie card
what feel the power inside you oh
yeah wait you don't talk too do you this
about to be on we need you for what's
coming who said kids can't fly and I
hope you ain't afraid this I don't know
if I can be who you need me to be your
grandma believed in you it's in your
blood I've waited a thousand years for
this
moment I am the guardian we've got this
zodiac up oh
yeah
me
you know that it's coming yeah
said know
com and now presenting the amazing
zodiac
War Tas Apprentice tells a story of a
teenager Tom he found a magical world
and he learned to become the guardian
and work with the 12 Zodiac to protect
the world zodiac up
we're very lucky we have a great cast of
top Asian American artists that do the
voices of a characters in the
movie hey no bining necessary all right
we spoke about
this Who Dares wake the empress nura You
Walk Two Worlds now team zodiac assemble
whatever I need to know to be a guardian
you have to teach
me you ain't seen nothing yet
I'll show you what TR tastes like
attack we got to free the other zodiac
go go go what the heck just
happened how about we all take a break
and cool
off with the power of the Phoenix I can
remake the
world without
humans we got to save them all right
Zodiacs let's do
[Music]
[Laughter]
this